something that you fundamentally need to
understand is that tax is the way that
our society works it's the way it
functions okay if there's no attacks
then there's no roads hospitals schools
anything that you use but you don't
personally pay for like you come to
school and you don't have to like pay
money before you walk in the door or you
could drive on a road and unless it's a
toll road you could just drive on it all
those things are paid for by the
government collecting tax quick question
yeah okay all right so we'll get to that
goods and services tax it's just one of
many two of the other big ones are as
you were just talking about Ethan
if you earn money if you have income
then you have to pay even come tax right
you have to pay income tax there are
other kinds of taxes based on things you
earn or these by for example you might
have heard of a land tax so if you earn
land there's a tax attached there for
just think this is actually a really
clever way of doing things where don't
you agree with you know how much there
is because at the moment there's a bit
of a disagreement kind of what the
government is doing is say look we do
need to collect money from our citizens
so we can spend that money on behalf of
our citizens but the question is who
should we get that money from this
actually kind of makes sense if you want
to spending lots of money right that
means you should have lots of money and
that should be taxed right so this is
kind of what this is doing is collected
for people who are you know routinely
spending in one the more you spend the
more you're taxed if you say it a bit
more you don't have to worry about that
tax okay at the same time people who
earn more money they should be taxed
more because they have more capacity to
be able to pay for more okay yeah
well that's true that's exactly true and
there it's funny because the government
takes money away from its citizens but
also in situations exactly like that for
particular kinds of areas for example
family the government will give back
money for example you might have heard
of sailing right they do a whole bunch
of things but the particularly you're
talking about is and catch the work it's
called the Family Tax Benefit right the
larger your family is the government
will actually pay you fortunately
payments there you see that's actually
really clever you're like why don't they
just take this tax why do they take tax
and then give some back and the answer
is there are some people who spend lots
and lots and lots but they don't have
dependents they don't have families that
they need to care for so the government
doesn't need to hand that money back as
it was it's a very complicated system
but you can see there's lots of good
thinking behind it so let's have a look
at a quick example question eg if you're
buying say okay we were trying to tell
them so the tablet if you go ahead and
buy like say I don't know eight hundred
and thirty dollar
I don't Samsung Galaxy Note or something
like that if you're buying this I
shouldn't have started a platform anyway
if you buy this okay in Australia this
amount tends to include the tax in but
it might not right so let's just imagine
that this is the price that actually
costs and then the government is going
to add this okay sir let's work out
what's the GST on this
you see okay now just before I write
down the answer the way I get 83 dollars
I can think of it two ways I'm gonna
write down birth and socially it's 10%
10% I'll get rid of it
this can idea quick to do is 10% off so
that's how multiplication of 800 and
save that as you know 10% a nice
convenient number a way that you can
also get to that is to say it's 830 and
you divide by 10 which effectively lops
off the zero right and that's what
you're 18 or okay so if that's the GST
then the sale price how much you and I
as consumers have to pay will be the sum
of this day is that yeah okay Bernard
did you wanna start standing out oh I
can't well let's all cut it yeah so I'm
going to put my working down right so
I've got how much it actually costs and
then I've got this little extra bit that
the government's going to grab and take
for itself okay and so let's see who's
got an answer who can didn't see no
heads right yeah yeah 913 I heard it a
couple excellent ah they got done